we talked a couple of weeks ago about
this kind of sad downfall of Bill Maher
a guy who I generally used to like and
still think has valuable insights on
some issues I have a really great
illustration that was sent to me by a
viewer yesterday about where Bill Maher
really has gone off the rails and this
is a clip from an interview he just did
with Jake Tapper from CNN Bill Maher has
been sort of anti-woken that he's been
arguing against wokeness and saying that
this aspect of the left is is bad and
you know to the extent that the left
goes too far with identity politics or
whatever the case may be you can find no
bigger critic than me when I find an
element of the left that I don't like I
call it out and there are sometimes some
consequences to it some in my audience
don't like me doing it but I try to make
those call outs proportional to how
significant these things are within the
left fine Bill Maher has asked what is
woke and he spits out a word salad it's
like a chop chop it's like a confetti
salad the ones where you it's almost
like little tiny bits it makes no sense
he says things that aren't true and this
clip
is really a microcosm of everything that
has gone wrong with Bill Maher take a
look at this and wokeness like how do
you define wildness because I hear
people use the term all the time and it
means something different to to
everybody well again I think it's this
collection of ideas that uh are not
building on liberalism but very often
undoing it
I mean five years ago Abraham Lincoln
was not a controversial figure among
liberals we like to
now they take his name off schools and
tear down his statues okay neither of
those things are happening so Bill Maher
is asked to Define woke and he says it's
anti-liberal stuff like the left taking
down statues of Abe Lincoln and renaming
schools named after Abe Lincoln I spent
a while researching whether those things
were happening there is one example of
an Abe Lincoln statue that was taken
down
and it was a really weird statue in
Boston where there was like that a black
man Weeping at the feet of Abraham
Lincoln and and it's a really weird vibe
okay
um it's been a controversial statue for
a while it doesn't actually have
anything to do with the recent statue
debate and it was removed and it was a
really weird statue but statues of Abe
Lincoln are not being removed there is
no effort to remove Abe Lincoln statues
you might be able to find one person who
went to some town hall meeting and said
we should get rid of enabling conception
but there's no actual effort going on to
remove them they're not being removed
there's this one weird one with a black
man Weeping at the feet of Abe Lincoln
that's it just doesn't really make sense
in 2023 so that's very deceptive and
then number two Abe Lincoln's name is
being removed from schools I have not
found a single example of Abe Lincoln's
name being removed from schools what I
found was a story from January of 2021
where San Francisco said we might name
like all the schools from the era during
which there was slavery and that
included one named after Lincoln it
didn't happen okay they kept the name so
one school might have been renamed and
it wasn't so so far
his two examples of what wokeness is are
things that are not happening Lincoln
isn't good enough for you
um you know five ten years ago I
Bedrock liberalism was we are striving
to be a colorblind Society where we
don't see race
um of course we see it but it doesn't
matter
that's not what woke is woke is
something very different it's it's
identity it's we see it all the time
it's always the most important thing
okay so listen as far as identity
politics goes I'm critical of identity
Politics on the left but the identity
politics is overwhelmingly on the right
does it exist on the left Shore I've
called it out for example when the
women's March said
that Jewish women are not intersectional
enough to be on the leadership because
they're really just privileged white
women
I thought that that was the left doing
identity politics in a way that is
disgusting and destructive and I called
it out when these things happen I call
them out but look at the identity
politics happening on the left
Christians are oppressed white people
are oppressed Nikki Haley why are you
running well I I'm not going to tell you
anything I disagree with Trump on but
I'm younger I'm a woman and I'm Indian
that's that's identity politics and I
don't hear any of these anti-woke
leftists calling it out I would respect
Bill Maher way more if he said I'm
against identity politics anywhere I see
it and here's a couple of examples of it
on the left it's always vaguely said the
woke identity politics give us specific
examples and I will be right there with
you in criticizing them but you've got
to point out that the identity politics
cudgel is being used by the right when
the identity politics is overwhelmingly
coming from them I would like to I would
like to see Bill Martin take that
approach as opposed to this word solid
definition of woke I don't think that's
liberalism I mean I could mention so
many issues like that I remember doing
um that show on HBO uh comic relief for
the homeless and
the idea then again among liberals I
thought was you know for the sake of
compassion can we get these people off
the street so they remember the question
was what is woke a roof over their heads
and now it's like how dare you try to
move the homeless this is where they
live it's like again you change the
definitions and then you say I'm more
conservative I believe what I've always
believed now that's true okay so the uh
as I pointed out a couple weeks ago
a lot of the Bill Maher stuff like the
kind of anti-vaxx and you know things
like this it's not actually new the
difference is that the environment has
become a more welcoming one for these
ideas of Bill Mars and so they're
getting more attention but Bill Maher's
been doing a lot of this routine for a
very long time so check out my video on
YouTube called they don't even know what
woke means I explain more about this
inability to Define woke but now Bill
Maher asks for a definition mentions two
things about Abe Lincoln that aren't
true and then vaguely mentions identity
politics and a comedy special that he
once did not hugely compelling stuff